today marks 59 years since this famous
photo was taken at a woolworth's lunch
counter in jackson mississippi it shows
a sit-in by civil rights activists
protesting segregation and the violent
reaction that it soon provoked
some who were there that day still
remember and elise preston is here with
more on that elise good morning jeff
good morning joan trump hour mulholland
is a white woman and a southerner who
had to break a long family legacy to
become a civil rights pioneer she
endured violence ostracization and even
prison time but her courage in demanding
change is now an inspiration to others
with a defiant yet determinedly calm
gaze this decades-old mug shot is what
80-year-old joan trump-hour-mulholland
jokingly calls her government-issued id
when you look back at that girl now
what do you think oh she wasn't bad
looking i think she got in good trouble
the great granddaughter of slave owners
the daughter of a segregationist
mulholland grew up in a virginia home
where black people were only accepted to
fetch and feed growing up what would
your mother
tell you about race tell you about about
black people they were diseased
and you had to be careful going to the
bathroom
that
because you might get diseases and i
just couldn't put it in words then
but i knew when i had a chance to do
something to make things fair i would do
it and that came with the sit-ins
sit-ins non-violent protests staged
nationwide during the civil rights
movement as a young college student
mulholland participated in dozens of
demonstrations people thought you were
crazy oh yeah and
some girls in the dormitory quit
speaking and others were slipping as few
dollar bills to help support the
movement she went on to participate in
the freedom rides integrated bus trips
throughout the south which challenged
jim crow laws to keep blacks and whites
separate her involvement landed her two
months in a maximum security prison for
breach of peace
less than three square feet of floor
space per prisoner things are dirty
and the food was pretty bad and
you know protein came from the insects
you were
largely thought of as dangerous a
traitor a race traitor i was just doing
what the spirit said do and the movement
became like a family we always had each
other's back this iconic photo snapped
on may 28 1963 shows the violence that
family endured while trying to integrate
a woolworth's lunch counter in jackson
mississippi memphis norman was being
pulled off his stool and kicked severely
and
the girls were pulled down it quickly
became obvious that i would be safer
sitting
on the empty stool where memphis had
been than i would in the crowd her faith
blocked fear and constant reminders of
the dangers the protester and freedom
rider faced surround the now
grandmother's home i had
a copy of my birth record
which was good for if you have to
identify
a body if someone gets killed it's a
form of identity even in all that
you weren't afraid
no
i figured the lord will see you through
joan's son loki is the founder and
executive director of the joan trump
hour mulholland foundation which hopes
to wipe out racism through education do
you feel that your foundation and
organizations that exist like it do you
think that they're needed even more now
you know the shooting in buffalo proves
it we spoke with the family just days
after the racially motivated attack in
buffalo as it was happening my mother
and the other freedom riders were on
stage in anniston alabama
talking about
the freedom rides and talking about the
bus that was bombed i got back to the
hotel my mind was just
was this on this going
you know
what more should i have done
what more do i need to do
for mulholland that work should be done
by everyone those wise with gray hair
and the young and passionate with bright
eyes i'm happy i did it i had the
opportunity and friendships we made back
then are good to the end but
more and more ends are coming
now joan trump hour mulholland's life is
expected to be the center of a feature
film produced by award-winning actor
anthony mackie the family says the film
is in development right now but hopes it
will be done at some point next year
which is the 60th anniversary of many
civil rights movement event and what a
life what a story to tell and that her
mother what she learned we talk about
learning hate but what her mother taught
she didn't take and she still found this
path she didn't take and she started out
as a freshman at duke and said that when
she first started participating in these
sit-ins college administrators wanted
her to undergo a psychiatric evaluation
that's just how
much the the community did not believe
in what she was doing and she's oh my
gosh she's a sorority member delta sigma
theta her son is an omega sci-fi
fraternity member yes they're amazing
they surround themselves with people who
everyone i when we were leaving i asked
i looked at her and i said thank you for
everything that you did and she replied
i did it for all of us which definitely
shows that you know when people are not
equal everyone is harmed amazing amazing
job what a wonderful story thank you